à la verrière un cabinet médical vide
l'un des médecins étant obligé de partir
pour raisons de santé
l'autre ne pouvait plus assurer les
frais du cabinet seule la commune se
retrouve sans aucun médecin depuis huit
mois
j'ai encore un médecin mais qui à 67 ans
au mais nul quand il va partir je sais
pas ce que je ferai ce que j'irais à
l'hôpital
qu'est ce que voulez qu'on fasse donc on
peut pas durer comme ça il faut
construire une maison de santé maisons
de santé qui n'est resté qu'au stade de
projet suite à un problème de santé suit
aussi une modification de la politique
de la ville qui ne souhaitait plus
mettre un budget dans la construction
d'un cabinet et qui voulait transférer
le support financier la même semaine
donc faire venir des médecins au sein
des mutuelles
donc il eu un désaccord avec les
médecins libéraux et depuis ce projet
est tombé à l'eau et on était sûr de 50
% des financements la ville devant
forcément de toute façon m 25 % et 25 %
restants qui n'était pas encore
complètement acquis c'est l'organisme de
mutuelle générale de l'éducation
nationale mgen qui a finalement proposé
d'ouvrir ses locaux même jeu elle nous
avait bien certifié que grosso modo on
pouvait occuper les locaux comme un
centre de santé que les médecins étaient
tout à fait libre
comme si c'était ailleurs une solution
intéressante financièrement pour les
collectivités locales mais qui inquiète
les médecins libéraux quant à leur
indépendance
le projet s'étend aujourd'hui acteurs de
la santé de la commune et municipalités
partagent la même inquiétude pour la
santé des 6000 habitants de la verrière
la mer a lancé des démarches auprès de
l'agencé régionale de santé avec la
maire du mesnil saint denis une commune
voisine dont les médecins arrivent à un
âge avancé dernier recours en date de la
verrière une pétition adressée à la rs
qu'elle fait signer à ses habitants je
pense que la mairie de la verrière
avaient anticipé ce départ en retraite
voilà malheureusement pour l'instant ça
ne porte pas encore ses fruits mais je
pense que ça va se mettre en place de
manière progressive mais encore une fois
je vous rappelle le principe de libre
installation des médecins des médecins
qui peine à se laisser séduire par
l'offre actuelle malgré les aides
proposées la verrière est classé en zone
d'intervention prioritaire par la rs il
faut un projet il faut souvent que les
anciens amène ce projet et parce que ses
anciens auront créé un projet de
notamment de cabinets de groupe et c'est
qu'ils attireront les plus jeunes à
venir
une situation d'autant plus préoccupante
que la verrière portent des projets
d'aménagement et de développement de la
ville comme dans le quartier gare bécane
avec la construction de 1000 logements